por segundo día consecutivo aquí en
Ucrania el país fue blanco de ataques
rusos con drones y las fuerzas
ucranianas derivaron 11 de los 15 drones
que Rusia lanzó durante la noche también
aquí en kiev estuvimos alarma esa noche
durante varias horas al mismo tiempo
continuaron los bombardeos sobre
infraestructuras civiles en varias
regiones causando dos muertos en el día
de ayer y al menos de 12 heridos Incluso
un hombre de
85 años en la región de saporilla donde
más de 40 edificios civiles resultaron
dañados en estos últimos ataques podemos
pensar en dos razones principales para
estos nuevos ataques aéreos sobre el
país primero Rusia parece hacer una
demostración de fuerza a los aliados de
La otan reunidos hoy en Viña segundo
atacando almacenes de cereales en nodesa
como lo hizo el día anterior Rusia
también demuestra desinterés en la
renovación de la iniciativa de granos
del mar Negro que finaliza el 17 de
junio de Julio una iniciativa que según
Fuentes pues Rusia amenazaba con no Ren